la rentrée scolaire 95 va coûter environ
4% de plus qu'en 94 événement planétaire
aujourd'hui le lancement par la société
microsoft bill gates de son système
windows 95 avec une campagne
publicitaire sans précédent
un milliard de francs investis à
l'échelle de la planète reportage
exclusif de nos envoyés spéciaux à ses
vrais nietzsche à cette enclave
musulmane tombée aux mains des serbes
l'ont juillet avec des rumeurs de plus
en plus insistants d'exactions
sinon de massacre autre titre beaucoup
plus léger développé dans un journal la
découverte de la nouvelle peugeot 406
l'invention d'un britannique une radio
sans pile qui se remonte comme un réveil
et enfin la dernière découverte du génie
français le fil à ouvrir les huîtres
madame monsieur bonsoir drame la nuit
dernière dans une cité d'epinay sur
seine où une jeune femme de 25 ans a été
tué et un enfant de 5 ans très
grièvement blessé par balles apparemment
lors d'une fusillade entre bandes
rivales
les agresseurs sont ensuite reportage
claude son père anne consigny et pire
moscovitch comme tous les enfants de 5
ans macquarie aime bien jouer et hier il
jouait sous un arbre en bas de chez lui
quand une balle lui a traversé le dos
son père l'a trouvé en rentrant du
travail
allongé sur une civière du samu le petit
garçon n'avait même pas compris ce qui
lui était arrivé
ça va aider vous savez j'ai un peu mal
si on est question
je sais pas j'ai commencé par 50,4 en
juin jusqu'au menti ce n'est pas vrai
c'est pas
j'ai eu pas mal à 12 j'ai mal j'ai mal
mais j'ai vécu grâce à la leçon je suis
révolté il devra d'être comme ça pour
elle n'en fera 5-6 rennais en france 5
c'est malheureux vers 20 heures un
groupe de cinq jeunes débarquent dans la
petite zone commerçante de la cité
d'orgemont deux d'entre eux sont armés
ils tirent apparemment au hasard et
touchent mortellement une jeune
algérienne de 25 ans qui se trouvait sur
ce trottoir
selon les témoins les agresseurs
seraient venus de la cité des gras
gonnet dans la commune voisine de saint
gratien
parce qu'une guerre demande oppose les
deux cités et ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'il ya eu échange de coups de feu
ils ont arrivés ici ou s'ils ont atterri
ici aussi à mois et demi comme ça mais
était au hasard au hasard les arrivées
là avec la voiture et terme à fordo au
n'importe comment
pour le maire de la commune il devient
urgent de s'attaquer à la prolifération
des armes à feu si ces jeunes étaient en
plus ce que l'on dit c'est à dire des
très jeunes personnes je pense qu'il ne
faut pas laisser s'installer
cette banalisation et que la police doit
prendre toutes ses responsabilités et là
encore nous sommes prêts à lui à l'aider
pour tout ce que nous pourrons faire
mais pour éradiquer les armes à feu des
cités en mai dernier déjà dans cette
cité un jeune homme en avait tué un
autre il s'agissait alors d'un différend
personnel et non deux bandes rivales
mais déjà le conflit avait dégénéré à
coups de fusil ce dernier week-end
d'août s'annonce particulièrement
chargée avec la fin des vacances pour
plusieurs millions de français
les responsables de la sécurité routière
sont d'autant plus inquiet qu'il observe
depuis quelques temps maintenant 1 et
relâchement dans la conduite des
automobilistes malgré la peur du
gendarme
les comportements irresponsables et
dangereux ont repris le dessus pour le
seul mois de juin la route a fait 25
victimes de puisqu'en 94 7 132 morts
avec gilles marine et bernard bonne arme
reportage dans l'un des départements les
plus touchés la gironde
attention il n'y aura pas de cadeau ce
week-end sur l'axé biarritz-paris 50
personnes sont mortes cet été dans le
seul département de la gironde dont
plusieurs enfants assis à l'arrière il
n'avait pas été attachées et cela les
gendarmes ne sont pas disposés à le
tolérer il y à beaucoup d'enfants
beaucoup d'enfants et ça on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça on ne peut pas
continuer et dans notre secteur
je sais que des mesures seront prises
pour sévir puisque
il ya le proc je pense qu a pas d'autre
solution sévir sur le port de la
ceinture de sécurité à l'arrière
autre facteur d'accident la combinaison
vitesse et manque de sommeil sur la
longue route du retour car beaucoup
reviennent du maroc d'espagne du
portugal il ya ceux qui savent s'arrêter
et puis ceux qui croient pouvoir aligner
des kilométrages record sans dormir
mieux de faire 1200 km pour tenir le
coup pour vieux cuir mais contre le
sommeil la volonté et les litres de café
ne sont pas toujours suffisants 31% des
accidents sur les autoroutes du sud de
la france sont dues à l'endormissement
il est médecin spécialisé réclame
désormais des campagnes de prévention
je crois que maintenant il faut dans son
appel au gouvernement pour que l'on
puisse mettre en place des campagnes de
prévention et d'éducation des gens quant
à l'hygiène de semaine au même titre que
contre l'école oui je crois que c'est
une en comportement pathologique obama
titre que la toxicomanie
alors pour que la fin des vacances ne
tourne pas à la tragédie sachets dormir
et prendre même sur l'autoroute le temps
de vivre quelques 65 mille tonnes de
cahiers environ 8 million de cartables
vont être achetés dans les toutes
prochaines semaines
cette rentrée scolaire 95 va peser un
peu plus lourd dans le budget des
familles environ 4% de plus dû surtout à
l'augmentation de la tva de 2% dû
rentrer donc pour nos chers bambins dans
tous les sens du terme
reportage il avait aidé les embrassant
quand il s'agit des achats pour la
rentrée grégory qui passe en 4e ne
quitte pas sa maman d'une semaine c'est
en principe lui qui choisit va-t-il
opter pour un cartable à 30 995 ou à 400
francs
il est hanté par le haut de gamme kuhn a
ses raisons sont assez solides
alors il faut quoi bien basis parce que
soit avoir acheté d'autres parce qu'ils
sont tous les croyants des charcutiers
et les cahiers de brouillon
leurs prix varient de 1 franc 20 à 25
francs 80 cab
les écarts sont de plus en plus grand en
fonction des marques et du type de
magasin difficile de prévoir les
dépenses d'une année sur l'autre
je me vois à peu près sur l'année
dernière qui était ça m'est revenue avec
les équipements sportifs et tout ça à
900 francs je pense que cette année ça
va avoisiner les mille francs sans doute
puisque les fournitures ont beaucoup
augmenté cette année à cause de la
hausse du prix du papier et de celle de
la tva et une fois qu'on a rempli le
cartable ce n'est pas fini il y a encore
les vêtements la cantine la carte du bus
et quelques fantaisies comme ces
nouveaux classeur à l'effigié de
mannequin grégory ça le laisse coi
je trouve qu'ils sont un peu trop cher
par rapport à certains autres et je ne
m'intéresse pas à beaucoup au top model
quoi sarr est il une exception depuis un
mois ça se vend comme des petits pains
rappelons qu'une ars l occasion de
rompre scolaire de 15 cents francs par
enfant est attribuée aux familles les
plus modestes cette mesure concerne
environ 5 millions 300 mille écoliers
événement planétaire dans le monde de
l'informatique la société microsoft
numéro un mondial des logiciels de micro
ordinateurs lance en effet aujourd'hui
son nouveau système d'exploitation
windows 95 windows pour fenêtre qui
permet de rentrer dans le système
informatique
un événement accompagné d'une campagne
publicitaire sans précédent un milliard
de francs ont été investis sans compter
les reportages dans les journaux
télévisés
bill gates propriétaire de microsoft
l'industriel le plus riche du monde est
en passe de s'assurer un monopole quasi
absolu sur l'un des secteurs essentiels
de l'activité humaine et certains
dénoncent déjà là tout puisse
de citizen gates le big brother du
troisième millénaire
reportage de notre correspondant aux
états unis figaro hier soir dans la nuit
étoilée de washington new york ou
ailleurs des milliers de vendeurs
préparer l'événement l'entrée du dernier
microsoft un produit simple qui devrait
permettre à tous de jouer la même
partition
la symphonie d'un nouveau monde les
américains elle est il attendre l'heure
ou cendrillon va se coucher pour courir
eux-mêmes vers l'offre informatique
la réponse est off comme ce oui ici la
fable conte l'histoire des puces qui
sont sa vente et celle des souris qui
n'ont pas tout
la tête de mickey pourquoi es-tu ici
pour le windows 95 et tu connais les
ordinateurs we do avec depuis longtemps
depuis j'ai deux oreilles
et quel âge as-tu 6 c'est le décompte
l'heure est proche les douze coups ont
sonné et il ya ceux qui veulent être à
l'avant-garde avant les autres
j'espère que je suis une première je
veux être le premier de mon quartier à
l'avoir à l'ouverture pour parler
business la séance a été assez
mouvementée
chacun veut son coffret en fait même des
stocks il a gagné les doigts sur le
clavier
il est content les télé en direct ou en
différé ont rendu compte de l'événement
c'était absolument incontournable et
c'est certainement cela le secret de cet
éternel adolescent à lunettes qui
traverse la vie en changeant le monde en
or sans avoir l'air d'y toucher
après cette première nuit d'ivresse
informatique le grand triomphateur est
sans conteste l'homme le plus riche du
monde bill gate qui vient de démontrer
qu'on peut obtenir un produit de qualité
en investissant des millions de dollars
il vient aussi de faire la démonstration
que l'on peut obtenir de la publicité
gratuite
il a fallu quatre ans pour mettre au
point ce nouveau système d'exploitation
windows 95
le but de la manoeuvre est de rendre le
maniement de l'ordinateur aussi simples
ou presque que le magnétoscope et
surtout de permettre aux utilisateurs de
se relier au gigantesque réseau internet
reportage jean-claude allanic passe
castellitto on ne peut pas vraiment dire
que les français se sont rués
les américains sur le nouveau logiciel
microsoft même si les accros de la micro
attendait avec impatience la grande
innovation technologique promise par
bill gates
la dernière arme du conquérant américain
d'informatique la voici sous forme de cd
rom ou de disque est vendue entre 700 et
1000 francs 95 et plus puissant que
l'ensemble des systèmes d'exploitation
qui sont disponibles sur le marché y
compris évidemment windows 3.1
c'est un système qu'on appelle 32 bits
heures ça paraît tout de suite
extrêmement technique
il s'agit en gros de passer à une
autoroute a32 voir alors que par le
passé on était plutôt subito dases voit
donc plus de puissance pour l'ensemble
des applications effets concrets de
cette puissance une plus grande rapidité
au démarrage une grande souplesse de
travail et la possibilité d'effectuer
des tâches multiples en utilisant
simultanément plusieurs fonctions par
exemple imprimer un document tout en
continuant à calculer ou à remplir son
agenda
mais peut-on réellement dire que c'est
une véritable révolution
c'est une révolution pour microsoft en
réalité c'est vrai que micro que windows
95 ressemble un petit peu à ce qu'apple
fait depuis déjà plus longtemps
désormais microsoft est donc
technologiquement armes égales avec son
principal rival le système macintosh qui
fait la force d'apple technologies apple
offre ses fonctionnalités depuis au
moins une dizaine d'années je crois
qu'il faut bien avoir en tête que il ya
eu le défi de la fin des années 80 qui
était la facilité d'utilisation
apple est reconnu comme étant le leader
mondial dans ce domaine
il n'a toujours pas été rattrapé pour
gagner cette guerre bill gates a dépensé
un milliard de francs mais ce qui est en
jeu c'est aussi la suprématie totale de
microsoft tout le monde de
l'informatique et pas seulement sur
celui de macintosh et d'apple
ce nouveau système devait être mise en
vente en france seulement le 4 septembre
en fait la promotion
vous voyez a été avancé essentiellement
par crainte des piratages crâne pas tout
à fait vaine lorsque l'on sait qu'à
moscou
des copies piratées de windows 95
circule depuis plusieurs jours au marché
noir va 9 dollars pièce soit environ 50
francs les représentants de microsoft
estime qu'en russie seulement 4 à 6 % du
matériel software a sont achetés dans
les magasins agréés
la rentrée sociale le ministre de
l'économie et des finances alain madelin
a jeté un beau pavé dans la mare
syndical en affirmant que le
gouvernement pour réduire les déficits
publics avaient l'intention de remettre
en cause un certain nombre de mauvaises
habitudes et davantage acquis
déclaration qui a provoqué une réaction
indignée et unanime des responsables
syndicaux qui parle ni plus ni moins de
provocation laurent bègue ce lieu la
remise à plat des comptes sociaux qui
sera au coeur de la rencontre juppé
syndicats les 4 et 5 septembre
mais déjà alain madelin le ministre de
l'économie jette un pavé dans la mare il
veut que les fonctionnaires cotisent
pour leur retraite
aussi longtemps que les salariés du
privé c'est à dire 40 ans au lieu de 37
et demi une idée provocatrice estiment
les syndicats en tout cas moi je
considère qu'on ne peut pas se dire
chiche et et moderne et société de
progrès si on aligne les acquis sociaux
sur les plus mauvais lemieux de
l'alignement là ça serait en cas
d'espèce de dire cherchons pas de
retraite la roseraie fascine les
fonctionnaires sont inquiets alors de
son côté leurs ministres jean puech veux
les rassurer
cette mesure dit il n'est pas
d'actualité mais les autres sources de
tension ne manquent pas pour réduire les
dépenses sociales
le gouvernement parle par exemple de
moduler les allocations familiales en
fonction du revenu
surtout il pourrait remettre en cause
l'attribution automatique du rmi bien
sûr aujourd'hui qu'il y a des gens qui
quasi exclusivement d'allocations qui
proviennent de l'état ou de la
protection sociale mais pourquoi est ce
comme ça parce que ce pays créé de la
richesse tout en créant de la pauvreté
du chômage
quant à la csg certains syndicats
seraient d'accord pour l'augmenter et
l'élargir à tous les revenus
à condition que cela serve à financer
une vraie réforme de la sécu et pas
seulement à combler son déficit 120
milliards pour 94 et 95
au-delà de cette vague notion d'
avantages acquis le gouvernement entend
manifestement mettre un terme françoise
laborde un certain nombre de privilèges
fiscaux
oui il y aurait en france pas moi 216
privilège est plutôt sans cesse façon
d'alléger ses impôts alors ça va de
l'abattement forfaitaire accordé aux
professions les plus variés les
journalistes on sait mais aussi les
scaphandriers les polisseurs de pipe de
saint claude où les hôtesses de l'air
à cela s'ajoutent toutes sortes de
déductions liés à certains
investissements sicav assurance vie ou
encore placements dans les départements
d'outre-mer l'idc annoncé cette année
les privilèges que l'on supprimera l'an
prochain de façon à ce que ça ne porte
pas sur les revenus
95 mais sur les revenus 96 ce qu'il est
souffrant c'est le temps de se préparer
dont le budget présenté le 20 septembre
il y aura tout de même des mesures qui
s'appliqueront
immédiatement on connaît les deux
principales prêt à taux zéro jusqu'à 120
mille francs pour les ménages modestes
qui achètent un logement et puis aide
aux personnes âgées dépendantes au
gouvernement en espère la création de 50
mille emplois tout ça est évidemment
plus populaire que la suppression des
privilèges
on a encore un peu de répit mais le
gouvernement l'a sûr c'est inéluctable
ça grogne également dans les campagnes
notamment en corrèze le fief de jacques
chirac où des commandos de jeunes
agriculteurs ont muré est la nuit
dernière les portes d'une quinzaine de
trésorerie ces éleveurs bovins et
d'ovins espère ainsi dénoncer je les
cite le silence des pouvoirs publics à
dans les désordres monétaires qui ont
frappé leur trésorerie
les pouvoirs publics ont cousu leur
portefeuille nous avons voulu le leur
ferme et vivaces heures le ministre de
l'agriculture devrait annoncer très
prochainement de nouvelles mesures dead
ou en faveur des éleveurs
à noter également qu'en allemagne la
bundesbank a abaissé d'un demi pourcent
deux de ses taux directeurs
une décision qui
donne des marges supplémentaires à la
banque de france le ministre de
l'économie alain madelin a d'ailleurs
plaidé pour une nouvelle et rapide
baisse des taux d'intérêt les suites de
l'enquêté sur l'attentât du rer
saint-michel la justice française ne
lâche pas la piste suédoise
malgré la libye fournit par abdelkrim
des neiges un mandat d'arrêt
international transitant par interpol a
été transmis aujourd'hui aux autorités
suédoises
comme vous allez le constater avec ce
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
stockholm pascal tous ces bons et claude
sicard abdelkrim des neiges ce n'était
pas vraiment un militant clandestin la
mosquée de ring wegen à stockholm l'imam
ici est considéré comme modéré
en son absence les visages se ferment au
nom d'abdelkrim daineche et à celui du
journal alan sar les fidèles ont peur
est ce que vous connaissez abdelkrim des
neiges
non est ce que vous avez eu vent autour
de la communauté musulmane ici à
stockholm d'activités islamistes
non les gens prenaient lansar com
comment c'était reçu cette distribution
en général c'est pas le zodiaque et pas
n'importe qui reprend simple curiosité
je pense pourtant des neiges a bien été
interpellé ici par la police en mars 94
à la demande de lyman qui ne met pas le
voir distribuer lui et ses amis
alan sarr organe officieux du gia à la
sortie de la prière
officiellement alan s'arrête un journal
clandestin
pourtant ici en suède comme le démontre
le journal libération
il a presque pignon sur rue en voici la
boîte postale indiquée sur certains
numéros valenza elle se trouve dans un
centre commercial dans la banlieue sud
de stockholm à deux pas de chez
abdelkrim des neiges en suède
seule une société peut posséder une
boîte postale le titulaire de celle-ci
est un ami de des neiges marchands de
télévision
nabil assad dad lui aussi a été
interpellé lors de l'incident de la
mosquée en 94
il n'a pas souhaité répondre à nos
questions son lien avec alan ça répond
qu évident que ce temps la suède a
toujours solide son activité la police
secrète suédoise devrait mettre au moins
trois semaines pour rechercher les liens
entre abdelkrim daineche et un éventuel
réseau terroriste une chose est sûre en
tout cas l'activité de des neiges au
sein du journal al zahar considéré comme
clandestin est liée au gia était
parfaitement connue des autorités
ici en suède bataille navale et
médiatique en vue dans le pacifique sud
autour de la tôle de murs roi où les
essais nucléaires français devraient
reprendre très prochainement
c'est la veillée d'armes alors qu'une
flottille d'une trentaine de bateaux
conduite par les militants de greenpeace
s'apprête à défier la marine française
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux josé
blanc la pierre bruno girodon ce matin
pour accueillir le rainbow warrior il y
avait surtout des journalistes il n'ya
qu'il se trame quelque chose japonais
allemands australiens sont de plus en
plus nombreux chaque jour et tahiti est
sous haute surveillance médiatique un
battage loin d'impressionner les
polynésiens sur le quai quelques curieux
et une poignée de militants seulement
venu contre la reprise des essais
nucléaires et s'est jamais on peut pas
arrêter
il ya un autre moyen aussi fait de
demander notre indépendance
je passe le seul moyen et puis surprise
sous le soleil polynésien le larzac
ces éleveurs de brebis militants d'une
autre époque ont cassé leur tirelire
pour venir jusqu'ici en voilier ou en
pirogue par tous les moyens
ils ont dit vouloir se rendre eux aussi
à mururoa ça fait 40 ans que je lutte
contre la bombe a tenu que je pense que
jusqu'à 70 ans maintenant et je pense qu
il y eut jusqu'à la fin on se sent pas
dépaysé d'être ici watch dans le
discours qu'ils ont tenu ce matin je
retrouve tout à fait la lutte que nous
on a tenu aussi colliers de coquillages
et chapeau de paille quelques
polynésiens amis montent à bord du
navire qui soutient leur cause
puis pour contenter l'appétit des médias
conférence de presse de greenpeace qui
n'attendait que ça pour rappeler son
intention d'empêcher les prochains tirs
nucléaires
on va pas de définir nos plans l'avant
ont simplement on peut dire que
dans toutes les actions qui ont été
effectués par greenpeace depuis une
vingtaine d'années dans cette région
nous sommes rentrés dans la zone
d'exclusion parce que nous pensons que
c'est la manière la plus forte de nous
faire entendre
dans quelques heures le rainbow warrior
quittera tahiti direction mur euros à la
il retrouvera une flotille composée
d'une trentaine de bateaux premier
objectif
une rencontre entre les différents
skipper pour définir la tactique à
adopter
en israël les spécialistes de la lutte
antiterroriste viennent d'obtenir un
succès important en arrêtant deux des
cerveaux d'un réseau de poseurs de
bombes du mouvement hamas et en
interpellant une trentaine de militants
du hamas pour la plupart originaires de
la ville de naplouse ou également été
retrouvés un véritable arsenal
clandestins reportage dans cette ville
de notre envoyé spécial au niveau des
mers naplouse est à deux heures de route
de jérusalem
ce bel immeuble planté au milieu d'un
champ aurait très bien pu sauter samedi
dernier lorsque l'armée israélienne
investi les lieux
à deux heures du matin deux locataires
palestinien fait prisonnier disposer
d'un véritable arsenal armes
automatiques explosif du matériel
parfois rudimentaire mais paraît à
l'emploi l'atelier du parfait poseur de
bombe en quelque sorte et c'est
exactement ce type d'engin qui a explosé
lundi dernier dans un des autobus de
jérusalem les cerveaux des attaques
kamikazes de jérusalem et de tel aviv le
mois dernier font la une aujourd'hui de
tous les journaux ils sont issus de la
fameuse école ayache cet ingénieur qui
se cache dans gaza et qui règle toutes
ces attaques avec munitie l'un des
suspects arrêtés est originaire du camp
de réfugiés de balata tout près de
naplouse
une sorte de bidonville où ici on est
plus proche du fatah re délaissé rares à
pâte dure hamas la mère d'abdul ma série
5 qui seraient les commanditaires des
attentats ne lâche plus la photo de son
fils depuis qu'elle a appris son
arrestation elle vit ne rien savoir sur
ses activités
elle précise simplement qu'il
poursuivait tant bien que mal ses études
islamiques et qu'il avait déjà connu la
prison en 88 sa soeur nous livre cette
information supplémentaire
il m'a appelé de prison dit elle il a
demandé un avocat et il est malin
cela faisait sept mois qu'abdoun la
série ça a été recherché par la police
israélienne
et c'est sans doute avec l'appui discret
de certains palestiniens qu'il a été
localisée ici derrière cette porte
les agents israéliens qui poursuivent
leur mission dans naplouse annonce al
avance une fois n'est pas coutume ils
ont procédé à de nouvelles arrestations
et les activistes du ramasse ébranlée
après ce coup de filet vont sans doute
chercher à prouver qu'ils sont toujours
opérationnels en essayant de frapper à
nouveau
dans ce climat les négociations
continuent et même s'accélère israël et
olp
elles sont parvenus aujourd'hui un
accord de principe très important sur le
partage de l'eau en cisjordanie sérieux
quoi que dans les relations entre pékin
et washington alors qu'hillary clinton
la femme du président est attendu très
prochainement en chine pour participer à
la conférence mondiale sur les femmes
le militant des droits de l'homme
américain d'origine chinoise
harry ou a été condamné à 15 ans de
prison pour espionnage entre guillemets
avant d'être expulsés du territoire
chinois
comme en terre girondine chine ou
courber devant le tribunal harry ou
écoutent la sentence qui le condamne à
15 ans de détention pour espionnage
assortie d'une mesure d'expulsion
ce militant des droits de l'homme
naturalisé américain après avoir passé
19 ans dans les prisons chinoises est
arrêté à son arrivée en chine le 19 juin
dernier
une arrestation qui ne doit pas le
surprendre outre mesure puisqu'il s'est
intéressé de près au travail dans les
prisons et au trafic d'organes tout
l'été madame goût manifeste effet ce qui
est en son pouvoir pour éviter que son
mari ne soit publié l'expulsion du
ressortissant américain aujourd'hui
quelques heures après le jugement
intervient dix jours avant un événement
majeur pour l'image de la chine
la quatrième conférence mondiale des
femmes réunies par les nations unies à
pékin et qui doit accueillir entre
autres personnalités
la première dame américaine hillary
clinton à huit actuellement dans un
avion à destination de san francisco la
guerre en bosnie la forpronu a commencé
de retirer ses casques bleus de gorazde
laissant donc cette enclave et ses
soixante mille habitants sous la
protection tout à fait hypothétique de
la force aérienne de l'otan
une autre enclave musulmane elle aussi
sous la protection théorique de l'onu
l'enclavé de srebrenica est tombé aux
mains desservent le 11 juillet dernier
on sait maintenant que la prise de cette
ville a été accompagnée de nombreuses
exactions d'exécutions sommaires pour ne
pas dire de massacre c'est en ce sens
que conclut le rapport établi par le
polonais tadeusz mazowiecki
avec ce rapporteur des nations unies
pour les droits de l'homme reportage
exclusif de nos envoyés spéciaux jacques
merlino et jan janssen qui ont pu
pénétrer dans cette ville désormais sous
contrôle serbe
la route qui mène à srebrenica n'est pas
sûr et doit être emprunté à vive allure
des tireurs isolés sont encore cachés
dans les maisons en ruine qui sur une
vingtaine de kilomètres bord de cette
route
toutes les maisons sont détruites aussi
bien celle autrefois occupées par des
musulmans que par des orthodoxes dans ce
bal insa le spectacle est pire encore
contrairement à ce qui avait été dit la
ville n'est pas tombé sans résistance
les combats ont duré une semaine et
aurait fait 3000 morts avant que les
40000 habitants ne soient chassés par
les serbes
les appartements étaient vidés et les
rues sont jonchés de restes de probables
pillages dans cette ville fantôme
quelques habitants des serbes qui
reviennent maintenant officiellement ils
sont un millier mes cinq frères ont
disparu et je suis sans nouvelles d'eux
depuis trois ans ce sont les musulmans
qui les ont enlevés
je ne sais pas où estime la haine entre
communautés et est sans limite
la mosquée vient d'être détruite mais il
est interdit d'en filmer les restes
auparavant le cimetière serbe avec sa
chapelle avait été profanée permet le
bepa ici
dans cet endroit pendant qu'ils étaient
là ils ont fait une épave de me produise
mais si les serbes se plaignent ils sont
pourtant accusé d'avoir commis des
crimes de masse six mille musulmans
auraient disparu et selon l'onu
des exécutions massives aurait eu lieu
ce que dément le maire de srebrenica
ils demandent quel dégoût rythmant et
formellement des exécutions qui était le
choix quant aux allégations de charnier
fait à partir de photos satellites
il répond ne suggérons valeo terrain
foot alain perrin de foot pour leur est
envoyé des équipes d'experts qui
pourront à partir des photos d'étamines
exactement ce n'est pas si simple
d'abord parce que les photos satellites
ne sont pas précisent dans leur
définition
ensuite parce que sur place les preuves
ne sont pas évidents ainsi le stade de
srebrenica
il ya bien une pelleteuse de la terre
fraîchement remuée et sur un mur
d'enceinte des impacts groupe et de tirs
de gros calibre mais au fond de la
tranchée un câble pour le téléphone
quand un autre stade celui de kassab a
le seul être localisé précisément par
les photos satellites
on y remarque rien de particulier la
vérité sur des crimes de masse à
srebrenica sera sans doute très longue à
établir mais quel que soit le résultat
des enquêtes qui seront effectués le
spectacle de cette ville dévastée suffit
à témoigner de la cruauté et de la folie
qui ici se sont emparés des hommes
c'est donc pression internationale le
zaïre a finalement décidé de suspendre
les exécuter expulsion pardon massive de
ronde et de brume des d'origine hutu qui
avaient fui par milliers dans les
collines sans eau ni nourriture
cela pour échapper à ce rapatriement
forcé un vaccin contre l'herpès buccale
et génitale va être très prochainement
mis à l'essai cette expérimentation
international auprès d'un millier de
couples devraient précéder la mise sur
le marché d'une protection efficace pour
ces infections pleine recrudescence
précision avec jean daniel flaysakier
les virus de l'herpès il y en a deux
types le type
ainsi celui qui donne le classique
bouton de fièvre
le type 2 est appelé virus de l'herpès
génital et comme son nom l'indiqué qu'il
touche indifféremment les organes
génitaux de l'homme ou de la femme ce
virus de type de pose de gros problèmes
chez la femme enceinte car il impose
pratiquement à tout coup de faire une
césarienne de peur de voir l'enfant ceux
contaminés lors de l'accouchement
de plus le virus de l'herpès et très mal
entre deux pouces il va se cacher dans
ledit ganglion nerveux
si bien que les médicaments actuellement
utilisés sont très peu efficaces on
essaye donc de développer des vaccins
depuis le mois de mars par exemple 1000
couples sont suivis à travers le monde
un membre du couple est touché par
l'herpès l'autre non on a donc vacciner
ce membre non contaminés et d'ici trois
ans ou devrait savoir si la protection
conférée par le vaccin est efficace
un sacré numéro la 406 dernière née de
la gamme peugeot et qui sera à l'une des
grandes attractions du prochain salon de
francfort
la 406 est destiné à remplacer la 405
lancé en 85 et 10 ans ça suffit
l'ugb aziz un éclos barnier ont eu le
privilège de tester ce nouveau modèle
une fable ce qui pourrait s'appeler
l'assise y aller le lion cette berline
française sera l'une des grandes
nouveautés du prochain salon de
francfort
même si elle n'a pas encore chanté tout
l'été la 406 la remplaçante de la 405
viendra rugir sur notre marché dès le
mois d'octobre
elle appartient à la famille des
berlines de moyenne gamme supérieure
dans le jargon professionnel le segment
m2 qui représente près de 20% du marché
toutes marques
mais actuellement avec 405k nous ont peu
près 2% du marché
nous avons fait jusqu'à 6% à notre
objectif c'est de revenir très
rapidement à ces 6 % c'est-à-dire de fer
entre 20 et 25 % du segment m2 la 406
inaugure la nouvelle signature de la
marque au lion avec de nombreuses normes
européennes
intégrer avant la date outre le
troisième feu stop des rétroviseurs
panoramiques des essuie glaces qui se
déclenche automatiquement avec l'appui
les vingt mille salariés de sochaux
centre de production de ce nouveau
modèle ont suivi des formations
spécifiques pour sortir cette voiture en
quatre ans lançait une voiture à 80 ce
n'est pas un record puisque certains
venant concurrents pour mieux
chez peugeot c'est la première voiture
condense en quatre ans mais on ne va pas
s'arrêter à ces quatre années son prix
reste secret pour le moment la cigale
n'est pas la fourmi et refuse pour le
moment de faire les comptes
suite de notre carnet rose le consortium
aéronautique européen airbus est heureux
de vous annoncer la naissance de son
dernier né l'a319 une variante plus
courte de l'a320 et qui pourra
transporter 124 passagers sur 5500 km ce
nouvel appareil à rouler symboliquement
aujourd'hui sur une piste de l'aéroport
d'hambourg
devant un parterre de 500 invités donc
nous henry spéciaux patrick collet et
philippe l'outil chez airbus on n'a
jamais construit d'avions plus petits
l'a319 la puce du consortium européen
mesure 4 mètres de moins que l'a320 dont
il découle directement 124 passagers
pourront prendre place à bord sur de
très courtes et moyennes distances
l'objectif avoué est donc faire une
navette fonctionnelle ou facile
d'entretien les applaudissements ont été
nourris puisque depuis ce matin airbus
possède désormais une gamme complète et
homogène du plus gros au plus petit plus
vous agrandissez une famille plus vous
donnez
des outils aux compagnies aériennes qui
sont souples et efficaces et et dans un
effet de famille qui réduit le recours
oui bien sûr où on nous faisons mal à la
concurrence l'a319 a le même poste de
pilotage que l'a320 et l'a321
les équipages ont donc la possibilité de
piloter ces trois appareils grâce à une
seule qualification la formation pour
passer de l'un à l'autre ne nécessite
que quatre pour cet avion qui n'a même
pas commencé ses premiers vols d'essai
80 une commande ferme ont déjà été
enregistrées de quoi exaspérer boeing et
mcdonnell douglas qui détenait jusqu'à
présent le monopole sur ce créneau des
petits avions
un anglais de 58 ans vient d'inventer la
radio à ressorts qui se remonte un peu
comme un réveil une invention qui n'est
pas uniquement un gadget et qui pourrait
par exemple favoriser certaines
campagnes sanitaires dans des pays du
tiers monde dépourvu d'énergie
isabelle bechler a rencontré leurs
inventeurs au sud ouest de londres sur
la tamise se trouve une toute petite île
il pas y à deux pas du grand stade de
twickenham
il faut passer le pont l'endroit et
piétons et c'est là que nous avons
trouvé le panonceau rustique qui
indiquait le havre de travaux belize
pour entrer dans la maison parce par
l'atelier
c'est là que de chavaux bricole des
outils pour handicapés invraisemblable
depuis 22 ans
mais sa dernière idée et révolutionnaire
une radio pour le désert j'écoute est
assez vieux gramophone avec son grand
pavillon
quand j'ai pensé si tous ces bruits
peuvent émaner de ce pavillon simplement
contraignant avec vous mouiller sur un
disque de blake a dit il doit y avoir
assez de puissance dans le ressort est
relié à la manivelle pour alimenter un
petit générateur et donc faire marcher
un autre type d'appareil ceci est
purement et simplement une radio a enfin
d'horloge voyez sur le dos c'est la clé
il suffit de tourner on remonte la radio
pendant 20 secondes pour recevoir 40
minutes d'émission solution idéale pour
les endroits isolés dans le tiers-monde
la radio dont voici les prototypes sera
vendu environ 150 francs dès que l'
usine de production sera opérationnel la
solution industrielle a été trouvé en
afrique du sud
outch havas a fait engager deux équipes
de jeunes handicapés et consécration
suprême le projet a reçu le patronage du
président sud africain
voilà tout juste trois semaines cet
homme merveilleux
mais imaginer la fierté de trevor et sa
radio avec sa photo sur son mur très
bien bayliss pourra goûter le succès de
son entreprise depuis les bords de la
tamise avec le sentiment du devoir
accompli
une invention pour plus d'information
plus de bonheur et de dignité dans le
tiers-monde encore plus fort que le fil
à couper le beurre le fil à couper ou à
ouvrir les huîtres
telle est la dernière trouvaille du
génie français ou plutôt du génie breton
jacques de vous et gabriel camilla on
rencontrait le bill gates de
l'ostréiculture
magique une huître qui s'ouvre aussi
facilement qu'une boîte de soda une
ouverture instantanée et sans effort il
suffit de tirer sur la languette les
dévs nu tout à fait simplement c'était à
la suite des fêtes de noël dont une
personne âgée qui me demandait d'ouvrir
des huîtres et à la longue ça devenait
laborieux je me suis intéressé de savoir
comment on pouvait en fin de compte
réagir pour ouvrir une 800 us penser
alors comment ça marche
les huîtres sont d'abord placées dans
une ossature et en celle où elles vont
s'ouvrir
on glisse ensuite autour du pied de
l'huître un fil d'acier inox un noeud
coulant qui sectionne la chair lorsqu'il
est serré c'est tout la mise en place du
fils demande un travail supplémentaire
mais les ostréiculteurs sont
enthousiastes
c'est sûr qu'il va falloir habitués le
personnel à travailler d'une façon parce
qu'il remet mieux nous demande une
contention plus quoi il faudra
s'acquitter
il fallait quelque chose pour ouvrir les
vitres et il était grand temps que ça
arrive parce qu' énormément de français
qui désireront jésuites mais qui ne
pouvait pas le frein c'était l'ouverture
des lignes simples et les professionnels
voient déjà une explosion du marché + 30
% experteer la réaction des
consommateurs semblent leur donner
raison
le fait de ne pas avoir de danger en
ouvrant vos hits combien d'agencés
intérêts doit pour acheter l'huître
miracle il faudra patienter jusqu'en
octobre et dépensé cinq fois de plus
environ par kg 5 francs ouvrir des
huîtres sans risque et d'appeler le samu
dans quatre mois jour pour jour le
réveillon de noël bon appétit et puisque
nous sommes dans la cuisine cette toute
dernière information prononce de bonn en
allemagne où les femmes du parti
social-démocrate réclament tout à fait
officiellement une nouvelle loi qui
imposerait la participation des hommes
aux tâches ménagères vos programmes sur
france 2 avec des trains pas comme les
autres ce soir le maroc
et puis le cri du hibou de claude
chabrol dernier journal vers 00h30 pour
compagnie de catherine ceylac demain
gérard leclerc dans les 4 vérités à 7h50
recevra jean jacques de peretti le
ministre des dom-tom au sujet bien sûr
des essais nuque
et en polynésie bon anniversaire à jean
desailly 75 ans aujourd'hui le dicton du
jour
un dicton historique aux subtils à la
saint barthélémy j'en fais à ma guise
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet et le point route de valérie
maurice demain à 13h vous retrouverez
alain chalon et j'aurai le plaisir de
retrouver à 20h bonsoir